non le problème c'est qu'effectivement
elle a beau être invités si toutes les
annonces voies de fait l'après midi
l'intérêt je sais que c'est votre ami
nantes où j'ai joué type runabout chapa
sexuelle alors non je vais si elle vous
adore l époque où il a dit ça bah quoi
vous adore était content d'être venu
selon l'espagne critique elle vous avez
l'amour d'haus im on peut preuve c'est
qu'elle aime beaucoup la caméra donc
même quand elle sait qu'elle va rien
dire dès que c'est fait mais elle vient
c'est un peu son souci fois non plus
alors allez-y vous ça votre première
intervention dans l'émission on attend
de voir les dix neuvième à utiliser
trentaine d'années la parole vous aviez
de trucs à dire bah oui mais l
annoncions alors je souhaitais scène on
l'a vite elle vient c'est vrai qu'elle
est hanté par les caméras et comme en
plus elle est très esthétique pourquoi
pas en revanche jean jacques et d'un
système qui est très pernicieuse c'est
le système du pilonnage
c'est à dire ceux est fou pendant que la
personne pas même jamais